[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire ces la 500ème émission et
oui déjà comme ça passe vite j'en
profite pour recevoir les sociologues
kaoutar harchi pour son livre comme nous
existons c'est le récit autobiographique
d'une enfant de l'immigration
postcoloniale né dans l'est de la france
à la fin des années 80 je recevrai
ensuite luc marescot pour son film
poumon vert et tapis rouge qui est sorti
en salles mercredi dernier c'est sur le
parcours d'un documentariste qui veut
réaliser un blockbuster avec leonardo
dicaprio pour défendre les dernières
forêts tropicales et ensuite le
photographe nicolas henry qui organise
la biennale photo climat paris dans 11
lieux en extérieur jusqu'au 17 octobre
pour sensibiliser le grand public à la
défense du climat et l'on commence tout
de suite par vous kaoutar harchi voici
l'image que vous avez choisie pour
illustrer ce début de xxième siècle
c'est une manifestation black lips
batteur oui en effet ce sont les
manifestations notamment qui ont eu lieu
quelques temps après la mort de georges
floyd et qui ont eu un écho important en
france aussi puisqu'on se souvient des
manifestations extrêmement importante
presque historique qui ont eu lieu place
de la république le 13 juin 2020 qui
avait notamment été organisée par le
comité adama traoré
et pourquoi black lips the water vous
semble si important aujourd'hui ça me
semble important parce qu'à l'échelle
mondiale et à l'échelle française en
particulier la question raciale
deviennent question qui porte en elle
des enjeux démocratiques de plus en plus
important de plus en plus de citoyens et
citoyennes prennent conscience des
inégalités qui se pose à cet endroit là
qui viennent croiser les inégalités de
classe et des inégalités de genre qui
pose aussi la question des inégalités
raciales en lien avec la question
écologique et donc il me semble qu'à une
forme de centralité politique
extrêmement forte qui vient qui vient
prendre naissance quand c est dans cette
question là comme nous existons paraît
donc chez actes sud c'est par ici qui
part de votre enfant son album en alsace
et va jusqu'à votre examen de 4e année
de sociologie
vous réussissez brillamment avec mention
pourquoi vous êtes vous lancé dans cette
entreprise par goût de l'autobiographie
par goût de continuer à construire ce
que de construire depuis un certain
temps maintenant c'est mon quatrième
récit chez actes sud et la question
autobiographique elle m'intéresse
évidemment beaucoup là qui sont des
écritures de soi m'intéressait beaucoup
je trouvais jusque là que c'était des
questions qui étaient encore très
dominés par les questions de classe est
encore très dominés par les questions de
domination masculine des sujets
absolument centraux mais j'avais le
sentiment que c'était aussi une question
qui continuaient à baignés dans une
certaine forme de confort nationale et
ce confort nationale en tant
qu'écrivaine qui parfois est renvoyé à
des formes de troubles justement delà de
la nationalité ça me paraissent
extrêmement important de pouvoir de
pouvoir l'inscrire à cet endroit là j'ai
apprécié que vous faites de la
sociologie sur vous-même dans un livre
comme celui ci c'est évident partir de
vous m'avez évident qu'en tant que femme
qui qui peut vivre des expériences
de racisation
c'était important pour moi de dire qu'à
un moment donné si j'étais un objet je
pouvais aussi pleinement être mon propre
objet pouvait aussi être celle qui
regarde celle qui regardaient celle qui
porte l'image est celle qui l'a dessinée
ça c'était quelque chose de très de très
enthousiasmant pour moi et politiquement
de très important décrivez une petite
fille qui regardent de très
régulièrement la cassette de mariage de
ses parents
mariage qui a eu lieu à casablanca en
1984 alors vos parents aiment regarder
cette cassette mais vous même dès qu'ils
ne sont pas là vous avez transavia
chercher à la regarder pourquoi ces
images sont-elles si importante comme je
le dis dans les premières pages du récit
j'ai découvert en regardant ces images
que mes parents étaient heureux à une
époque et moi je n'étais pas je n'étais
pas là jonathan je n'appartenais pas
encore à cette époque je n'étais pas
encore né et c'est quelque chose qui a
été très troublant pour moi de découvrir
que mes parents avaient une vie avant au
sein de leur société avant la menace jal
avant la france et c'est là où je crois
que j'ai compris que quelque chose
s'était s'était placé qui avait eu un
déplacement et que ses déplacements il a
été la source de beaucoup de questions à
la source de beaucoup de problématiques
nouvelles et je crois que c'est quelque
chose qui m'a donné le goût ensuite delà
de la recherche de la recherche en tant
que chercheur aujourd'hui mais de la
recherche aussi en tant que qu'activité
intellectuelle dans la france
contemporaine votre mère va vouloir vous
éloignez de votre quartier des garçons
d'origine arabe qui y vivaient au point
de vous inscrire au collège dans un
établissement privé catholique
est ce qu il a eu raison
ce qu'elle a eu raison c'est une c'est
une vraie question je sais qu'en tout
cas c'est ce qui s'est passé et moi ce
qui m'a beaucoup intéressé dans le fait
de refonder cette expérience là c'est
d'essayer de montrer aux lecteurs et à
la lectrice que ce déplacement qui s'est
opérée cette forme d'exil scolaire il
s'est opéré parce qu'à un moment donné
ma mère avaient intériorisé l'idée selon
laquelle pour réussir socialement dans
la france du début des années 90 il
fallait d'une certaine manière tendre
vers une sorte de monde centrale qui
était le monde des centre villes mais
aussi vers un monde
blanc c'est à dire un monde
fréquenté par les par les enfants de la
bourgeoisie et c'est quelque chose qui
en contrepoint me paraissait ma part est
toujours très très problématique de
considérer que pour réussir s'il réussit
il y a il faut il faut partir moi
j'aurais préféré ne pas partir j'aurais
préféré rester avec mes proches avec les
gens que j'aimais mais ça interroge il
me semble effectivement la question de
l'organisation scolaire d'inégalités qui
traverse les établissements et la
manière dont cette forme d'inégalité
elle se transforme par la suite en une
forme de regards posés posé sur le monde
cette histoire aurait pu être écrite au
début du 20e siècle par des gens des
jeux des enfants de province qui étaient
obligés de monter à paris où d'aller
dans des collèges qui préparait à la
suite
au fond ce que votre mère si vous vous
intégriez c'est le bois la mode ce
qu'elle voulait effectivement comme elle
le disait souvent à l'époque c'était
qu'il y a un avenir et je crois que
c'est quelque chose d'extrêmement
important pour certaines familles il est
évident qu'il y aura un avenir et est
évident que demain va va apparaître mais
je crois que pour ma pour ma famille
pour ma mère en particulier cet avenir
n'était jamais garanti et je crois
qu'elle a essayé de construire avec sa
propre énergie et ses propres réflexions
sa propre intelligence quelque chose
d'une place dans un monde dans un
univers dans une société française ou 7
places n'étaient absolument pas pas
garanti d'avancé vous le raconter quand
vous êtes en terminale vous réalisez que
les garçons ne sait pas les élèves c'est
les gars on pense déjà à l'après bac à
l'avenir justement qu'ils ont déjà une
place qui est déjà fait ils ont un beau
dossier qui est déjà prêt et vous n'en
avez pas eu vous apercevez que la
plupart des filles d'ailleurs non non
pas oui je crois que au sein d' au sein
des établissements scolaires encore une
fois la question des inégalités de genre
se pose véritablement il ya déjà
beaucoup de travaux qui ont pu être
développé à cet endroit là et mes
souvenirs sont extrêmement précis je me
souviens que nous les filles
effectivement on s'intéressait beaucoup
aux garçons et les garçons eux
s'intéressait beaucoup à leur avenir
ce qui à ce qu'ils allaient devenir et
je crois que c'est quelque chose qui
montre que les établissements scolaires
et que l'école en général absolument pas
poreuse et totalement poreuse pardon par
rapport à la question de ce qui se passe
en dehors d'elle et que c'est important
de poser sur cette école là un regard
critique est justement de ne pas la
sanctuary zay à l'excès en considérant
qu'elle est en dehors en dehors de ce
monde là revenons à votre arrivée dans
cet établissement
privé catholique
lequel vous allez faire toutes vos
études secondaires
qu'est-ce-qui qu'est ce qui a changé
pour vous à partir de là ce qui a changé
c'est que j'ai découvert un univers
assez conservateur assez ferme est assez
stricte un parent n'était pas eux-mêmes
conservateur fermé estrie non pas du
tout
non pas du tout il était et nous étions
une famille pleine de vie on parlait
fort on aimait se réunir on aimait
préparer à manger on est maire invité
des gens parfois pensé que ce n'était
pas le cas des familles catholiques et
bourgeoise dans cet établissement là et
au regard d'une forme de l'éducation
stricte qui y régnait moi c'est quelque
chose qui m'a qui va marquer j'ai vu une
sorte de wii de monde un peu plus fermé
un peu plus un peu plus un peu plus
ordonnée
prendre prendre place et j'ai dû
m'habituer à cela j'ai dû moi aussi me
redonner un peu j'ai dû apprendre à me
tenir j'ai dû apprendre à parler comme
il était important de parler à cette
époque-là aux professeurs aux autres
camarades et c'est donc oui c'est un
univers qui pour moi était été
conservateur la première impression que
vous avez c'est que vous voyez dans le
bus qui vous conduit vous avez dix ans
quand vous vous êtes dans ce bus qui
vous emmène dans cet établissement il
voyait des jeunes filles de votre âge
qui seront probablement des condisciples
du collège et qui sont que vous trouvez
toutes très belles parce qu elles sont
blondes avec des yeux clairs comme les
filles des séries télévisées que vous
regardiez en fin d'après-midi classe
mannequin ou ou premier baiser et or
c'est là c'est elle aussi qui vous
agressent les premières à cause de vos
cheveux justement c'est une scène qui a
été très importante pour moi écrire
parce que crois que quand on est un
individu ou quand on appartient à un
groupe qui est susceptible d'être visé
par le racisme il y as forcément dans
les trajectoires individuelles qui sont
les nôtres une sorte d'expérience
primordial qui serait on pourrait dire
celle de la rencontre justement avec
lara scène où l'on prend conscience que
finalement il ya des processus
d'altération qui nous qui nous marque et
c'était important pour moi de réussir à
retrouver cette scène primordial et 700
justement c'est celle qui se passe dans
ce dans ce bus où je rencontre des
jeunes filles comme vous le dites
justement que je trouve extrêmement
belle mais là réussie profiter du regard
la bienveillance du regard n'est pas
n'est pas la même et oui la question des
cheveux des cheveux bouclés la question
de leur texture la question aussi de la
déviance par rapport aux codes de la
féminité qui était en train de se
construire à l'aube de l'adolescence ont
fait surgir cette expérience où tout
d'un coup j'ai senti que mon apparence
compté et que mon apparence parler de
moi comme mon apparence parler pour moi
et que c'est quelque chose qui kim homme
qui me devançaient c'est quelque chose
qui me dépassait et je crois que j'ai
toujours cherché par la suite à dire
quelque chose de ce qu'on disait de moi
à dire quelque chose de ce qu'on disait
de nous donc c'est évident que mon
rapport à la sociologie par exemple mon
rapport à l'écriture littéraire mon
rapport à l'écriture de manière plus
générale s'inscrit dans cette volonté de
de ne pas laisser aux forces sociales le
dernier mot de ce qu'elle nous font
vivre et dans ce but vous allez de
rencontrer aussi votre meilleur ami
s'appelle khadija et qu'elle même
problème mais qui est elle aussi visée
par ces attaques
et au fond de vous en vous en vous
désignant comme différente elle vous
associe par la même occasion à quelqu'un
qui vous ressemble c'est quelque chose
qui a été très très riche à à étudier
c'est qu'effectivement quelque chose se
crée à cet endroit là qui est ce que
j'appelle dans le récit une forme de
parenté par la ressemblance il n'y a
rien qui nous lier cette jeune fille et
moi si ce n'est cette apparence est par
cette apparence là en vérité ce qui se
joue c'est une expérience commune de la
domination on part souvent en france en
particulier de communautarisme on parle
souvent de chose de cet ordre là comme
si les gens se réunissaient parce qu'ils
auraient quelque chose dans le sang qui
coule et qui serait et qui serait
similaire mais en vérité ce n'est pas du
tout ça ce qui pousse surtout à ses
formes de solidarité et à ses formes
d'entr'aide c'est que la domination et
communes c'est que le rejet commun et il
y à mon à mon sens à cet endroit là
quelque chose d'à la fois très beau des
gens qui s'unissent pour résister mais
aussi des formes d'amour et des formes
d'amitié qui naissent et qui viennent
faire exister quelque chose qui dépasse
l'apparence quelque chose qui rassemble
par une forme de projet politique pas
forcément déjà à cette époque là mais
par la suite c'est évident que c'est
quelque chose qui m'a beaucoup qui m'a
beaucoup intéressé et qui perdure quand
aujourd'hui on parle des six millions de
musulmans en france 6 millions n'en sais
rien d'ailleurs ce chiffre totalement
symbolique est ce qu'ils sont vraiment
musulmans on n'en sait rien à ce que
vous même vous êtes musulmane je les
ignore mais vous êtes catalogué comme
tel est-ce que forcément ça soude les 6
millions qui peuvent se sentir désigné à
ce moment là
alors c'est compliqué je sais pas
exactement ce que vous mettez derrière
le terme soudée mais en tout cas ce qui
est évident c'est que ça peut créer un
moment donné des sortes de processus de
conscientisation en fait c'est à dire
que la répétition de l'injustice la
répétition de l'arbitraire le fait de
comparer sa vie à son voisin le fait de
comparer son salaire à son collègue etc
etc fait qu'à un moment donné évidemment
vous rendez compte que vous appartenez à
un groupe minoritaire qui est traitée et
qui est construit depuis désormais très
longtemps comme un problème et je crois
que ça c'est quelque chose de
politiquement grave de dangereux et qui
d'un point de vue démocratique pose
aussi la question de l'appartenance
d'une partie de la société française au
corps national est ce qu'on observe
depuis quelques temps désormais c'est
effectivement la volonté de sortir de ce
corps national une partie de la
population en la traitant comme une
forme d' ennemi intérieur et ses
processus là à la fois en tant que
sociologue mais à la fois en tant
qu'écrivaine il m'intéresse car ils
disent quelque chose de la société
française qui doit absolument être pensé
et qui doit faire qui doit faire débat
vous raconter la mort d'un jeune de
votre quartier ce quartier justement que
vos parents ne veulent pas que vous
fréquentiez et qui vous attire forcément
parce que vous les avez connus vous avez
joué avec eux quand ils étaient enfants
ils habitent autour de chez vous il y en
a un qui meurt alors qu'il est détenu
par la police c'est très important pour
vous dans votre dans votre parcours
c'est important pour une chose
simple c'est que moi je suis une jeune
femme jeune femme et j'ai toujours pu
observer au quotidien le sort qui était
réservé aux garçons autour de moi au
garçon arabe au garçon noir garçons
racisées ça veut bien dire qu'il ya
quelque chose autour des masculinités
minoritaires autour des masculinités
minoritaire dans l'espace public qui est
particulièrement visée et en tant que
jeune femme je peut subir d'autres
formes de racisme une sorte de racisme
plus exotiques plus exotiques en mai la
question de ces hommes qui meurent qui
sont tués qui sont emprisonnés qui sont
contrôlés bien plus que la que la
normale vient dire à mon sens quelque
chose d'une forme d'une forme coloniale
de violence qui continue à se produire
et bien évidemment ça ça m'interroge ça
me révolte et ça même ça constitue le
coeur de ce sur quoi j'écris de plus en
plus vous écrivent également sur vos
retours au maroc pour les vacances
chaque été vous y passer un long moment
et vous apercevez que vos parents pas
sortant de mentir
je dis qu'ils mentent mais je dis aussi
qu'il mente d'une manière tellement
sincère qu'en vérité la frontière entre
ce qui est vrai et ce qui est faux ils
la font totalement disparaître et je
crois qu'à cet endroit là on est
typiquement d'autres abdelmalek sayad à
nommer la double absence c'est à dire
cette nécessité de faire croire aux
personnes que l'on a quitté qui sont
restés dans la société d'origine qu'au
sein de la société d'accueil tout se
passe bien tout va bien et qu en vérité
tout ça on a bien valu la peine et cette
idée là de se demander à ce que ça en a
valu la peine c'est quelque chose
effectivement sur lesquels mes parents
ne vont jamais absolument rien lâché ils
vont toujours vouloir faire croire que
tout ça a eu du sens et ça a du sens
mais c'est un sens qui est plus
ambivalent qui est plus contradictoires
qui est beaucoup plus difficile qui ne
laisse paraître et moi j'étais une sorte
de témoins de ces scènes là et
évidemment je voyais bien les jeux je
voyais bien la manière dont il essayait
de sauver quelque chose de leur face au
sens presque anthropologique du terme et
ça dit quelque chose de ses formes de
vie qui sont qui sont dédoublés et qui
n'obéissent pas à une logique propre et
donc ne bénéficie pas d'un confort et
d'une évidence
immédiate vous allez passer votre temps
au fond mais ça souvent les enfants de
l'immigration le raconte vous allez
passez votre temps à protéger vos
parents notamment votre mère
alors est-ce que c'est dû au fait que
vous avez fait des études
ou est-ce que c'est plus compliqué que
ça je crois que c'est plus compliqué que
ça parce que je crois que lorsqu'on est
un enfant on se rend compte plus ou
moins tôt que nos parents ne sont pas
simplement que des parents je pense
avoir découvert tôt que mes parents
étaient aussi des travailleurs que mes
parents étaient aussi des personnes qui
devaient aider leur propre famille dans
un autre pays et c'est ça veut bien dire
que l'ordre national et l'ordre raciale
et l'ordre de la migration
viennent bouleverser l'ordre familial et
que finalement ce qui relève de l'espace
public de l'espace privé n'est plus
aussi clairement situé que ça peut
l'être dans le cas de familles nationale
est pleinement pleinement installés en
france donc ce sentiment de protection
il dit quelque chose aussi de
l'inversion des rapports moi j'ai
beaucoup écrit sur le sentiment d'être
la mère de ma mère sur le sentiment
d'être la mère de mon père sur le
sentiment d'être leur meilleure amie sur
le sentiment d'être celle qui parfois
leur causera aussi des problèmes qui
augmentera leur inquiétude des choses de
cet ordre là et je crois que ça c'est
des sentiments que c'est un potentiel
émotionnel très fort à l'enfance mais
qui est pleinement politique
c'est-à-dire qui obéit véritablement aux
structures sociales qui expose ses
parents là à des situations qui les
dépasse mais sur lesquels ils vont
tenter malgré tout toujours de garder de
garder la main et quand vous êtes enfant
vous le voyez même si vous ne comprenez
pas vous le percevez et je crois que
dans mon cas ça a créé une forme de
sensibilité qui est qui est à l'origine
de beaucoup de choses survenu par la
suite vous avez utilisé très souvent
l'objectif raciale depuis d'autres début
de notre entretien
c'est une chose qui choque énormément
aujourd'hui qu'on parle encore de race
on veut y mettre la race au centre de la
société française en tant que problème
d'ailleurs et au fond c'est ce qui fait
que beaucoup de retir assiste
aujourd'hui sont considérés sont taxés
de racisme même qu'est ce que vous
répondez à ceux qui vous dit que tout ça
n'existe pas et qu'au fond il ya des
problèmes sociaux et d'ailleurs vous en
raconter un certain nombre votre livre
mais qu'il faut pas les matinées de
problèmes raciaux un point qui est
important quand on est sociologue ou
quand on est chercheur en sciences
sociales et même quand on est militant
la première chose qui est importante
c'est que quand nous parlons de cette
question là nous parlons de la race au
singulier et nous ne parlons pas des
races au pluriel les grâce au pluriel
renvoie au discours racialiste né au
singulier elle renvoie la question
sociale est elle renvoie au fait que des
individus sont historiquement parlant
renvoyer à un groupe naturel et qu'ils
sont inférioriser du fait de cette
appartenance il y avait beaucoup de
textes sont déjà revenus sur 7 sur 7 sur
cette question mais je crois que la
société française est une société qui
peine encore beaucoup à se représenter
comme ce qu'elle est c'est-à-dire aussi
comme une société postcoloniale c'est à
dire une société au sein de laquelle
l'imaginaire mais aussi les structures
de coûts du pouvoir mais aussi les
structures policières les structures
administratives
enfin même les structures juridiques
naissent directement de cette
organisation et de ce mouvement de
colonisation notamment de l'algérie dès
dès 1830 donc je crois que ces discours
là qui renvoie les racistes à quelque
chose de gênant pour eux c'est un fait
c'est évident qu'ils préféreraient vivre
leur racisme de manière beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus tranquille et sans et sans
opposition mais je crois encore une fois
que la question raciale ne se limite pas
à la société française qu'elle est
d'ordre mondial et que langer
démocratique et bien de réussir à
montrer que des individus sont traiter
inégalement du fait de leur apparence et
que dans une démocratie qui se veut
démocratique
c'est une chose qui est qui est
inacceptable et certains luttent dans la
rue pour cela et d'autres écrivent à ce
propos d'autres font même les 2 en même
temps et c'est quelque chose qui me
semble qui me semble une question
d'avenir viable tard archi je le disais
vous été en 1987 et donc vous vous
décrivez par exemple on est en alsace
vous avez grandi
décrivez les filles de votre collège
vous les envier janvier leur aisance
naturelle
alors que vous même vous voyez à 17 ans
à ce moment là déjà vieille sous
l'emprise de sentiments tels que la
honte la colère
dont vous n'arrivez pas à vous
débarrasser au fond à ce moment là vous
êtes une jeune fille issue de
l'immigration comme on dit rassurante
pour la société française parce que vous
aimeriez bien non seulement vous
intégrez parmi ces jeunes filles blondes
aux yeux clairs mais au fond on a
l'impression et vous avez séduit vous
traversé l'esprit à cela nous aimerions
leur ressembler on a l'impression
qu'aujourd'hui dans la nouvelle
génération celle qui est plus jeune que
vous qui pourraient être vos filles
peut-être elles ont plus du tout envie
de leur ressembler elles n'ont plus du
tout envie de s'intégrer elles ont elles
sont fières de ce qu'elles sont y
compris dans leurs imperfections dans
l'eure dans leur façon de mal parler de
ne pas s'intégrer justement est ce que
je me trompe ou est-ce que vous en tant
que sociologue vous avez cette même
cette même sensation
je pense que la question à ne se joue
plus en terme d'intégration de danse
d'intégration je crois qu'il y à une
appartenance à la société française qui
empruntent des voies très différentes et
cette voie n'est plus simplement la voie
scolaire et elle n'est plus simplement
la voie de la bonne présentation comme
comme vous le disiez mais quelque chose
qui est à mon sens important c'est de
voir que durant ces dernières années la
question des savoirs c'est beaucoup
construite je crois qu'une jeune fille
aujourd'hui qui à 20 ans 22 ans et qui
peut être à la fois victime de racisme
et à la fois victime de sexisme de
mépris de classe aussi je crois qu'à
lancer plus potentiellement sur ces
processus qui la vise que les personnes
qui appartenait à des générations
entières mais aussi parce que ces
questions là apparaissent de plus en
plus dans ces séries elles apparaissent
de plus en plus dans des débats des
chercheurs font en sorte que ces
questions deviennent publiques les deux
modèles il y à des modèles qui
apparaissent et il ya un potentiel
critique qui est de plus en plus
accessible et je crois aussi
par ailleurs que les inégalités en
france sont devenues tellement flagrante
qu'il est de plus en plus difficile de
fermer les yeux lorsqu'on les voit et
kylie a finalement des formes
d'aménagement il y a des formes de
résistance bien des formes
d'intelligence sociale qui vont émerger
et qui font qu'évidemment des discours
revendicatif vont apparaître pour faire
valoir ce que les gens estiment être
leur valeur et ça c'est quelque chose
qui me semble être
important puisque cela dit un élan de
vie saadi un élan de participer à la
société française et sadi un élan de
pouvoir faire en sorte que l'égalité et
la justice
baigne encore un peu plus la société la
société française vous même sous fait
partie de ces modèles en tant
qu'intellectuel réputé qui publient des
livres
qui passent à la télévision qui passe à
la radio et qui est connue en plus pour
son intelligence et sa beauté ce cas il
semble être vous faire défaut quand vous
étiez quand vous aviez dix ans pour ce
qu'il fallait être blonde aux yeux bleus
je pense que je ne sais pas si je suis
un modèle c'est pas ce n'est pas
réellement vers ça que je tends moi je
sais que j'essaie surtout de produire
des choses de produire du contenu et
j'essaie de dire des choses
qu'il n'est pas forcément toujours
bienvenu bien venu de dire
ma contribution je la vois deux sets de
cette manière là et j'essaie aussi
d'être à côté de me situer à côté des
personnes que moi je juge être des des
des modèles des personnes qui m'ont
inspiré et puis qui font par ailleurs
des choses que moi je ne fais pas comme
rassemblé des centaines de mille
personnes dans la rue lors d'une
manifestation par exemple si la banque
laxisme auteurs comme l'animateur comme
la figure dassa traoré par exemple ce
sont des choses moi qui m'inspire qui
m'inspire beaucoup et que j'essaie de
capter que j'ai c'est de réintégrer dans
mes livres pour que par la suite ça
perdure et pour que surtout ça puisse
aussi encourager d'autres personnes à
prendre la parole et a développé une
parole qui est critique une parole qui
est une parole de confrontation une
parole d'opposition parce que je crois
qu'il ya véritablement quelque chose qui
se joue là et les espaces médiatiques
malheureusement sont plutôt manquant à
cet endroit donc la littérature est
aussi un espace que j'essaie de
d'ouvrir ce sont aussi des formes de
tribune que j'essaie de créer pour moi
même et de créer aussi pour les autres
comme nous existons ça vient de paraître
chez actes sud bercy merci dr archi
d'avoir été dans cette 500ème donc d'
interdit d'interdire on se retrouve
juste après une pause avec luc marescot
[Musique]
luc marescot bonjour on va regarder tout
de suite la photo que vous avez choisi
pour symboliser notre époque
parce qu'elle annonce tout ce dont on a
parlé ensuite elle annonce le film alors
de qui s'agit-il moi je le sais pas ce
que j'ai vu le film mais pour les autres
alors il s'agit de francis hallé qui est
un botaniste experts des forêts
tropicales et qui à mon avis devrait
être aussi connu que cousteau pour les
océans mais c'est un monsieur plein
d'humilité plein de poésie qui se cache
derrière ces arbres donc du coup il est
moins connu mais il fait beaucoup pour
les forêts tropicales
alors vous même vous avez déjà réalisé
au moins une vingtaine de documentaires
sur les forêts tropicales et vous avez
fini par vous convaincre que le meilleur
moyen de toucher le grand public et de
l'amener à se dresser contre la
déforestation aveugle c'est de réaliser
un film de fiction un blockbuster avec
leonardo dicaprio télé le sujet de
poumon vert et tapis rouge votre nouveau
film sorti mercredi dernier en salle
dont voici la bande annonce
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'imagine un blockbuster un thriller
écologique qui donne envie d'agir
[Musique]
felli caprio alors il a dit quoi
luc marescot avant même de voir votre
film je me suis posé la question est-ce
que qu'est ce qui est plus difficile
c'est de sauver les dernières forêts
tropicales ou de réaliser un film avec
leonardo dicaprio
je dirais que les deux sont très
difficiles mais à des échelles
différentes
sauver les forêts ça pour moi ça devient
essentiel parce que le le bayer c'est
pour moi c'est une partie de la solution
pour pour notre humanité qu elle et
qu'on a deux écosystèmes qui nous font
respirer il ya les océans et les forêts
et les océans on voit bien que d'abord
ils pourront jamais doublé de volume
même si tous les toutes les calottes
polaires fronde etc les océans sont
malades ils sont déjà bourré de co2 de
blindés de plastique et ainsi de suite
et alors que les forêts on peut encore
les faire pousser et il est peu n'ont
pas l'effet à grandir à l'infini mais en
tout cas voilà on installait beaucoup
plus et et le végétal peut être une des
solutions donc du coup je me bats pour
ça j'ai rencontré francis hallé il ya
vingt ans je les ai vus comme un don
quichotte à il faisait le boulot de
david contre goliath a essayé de
défendre ses forêts là et je pouvais pas
rester les bras croisés mon arme c'était
l'image donc je me suis dit il faut que
je fasse quelque chose et donc j'ai
enchaîné douze documentaires sur les
forêts tropicales
comme moi vous avez pu voir que ça n'a
pas beaucoup aidé à arrêter les
tronçonneuses donc du coup je me suis
dit qu'est ce qui cloche en fait c'est
vrai que les documentaires sont regardés
souvent par des gens déjà convaincu donc
du coup c'est bien parce qu'on consolide
une base de gens qui savent mais il faut
polliniser plus largement photo ce n'est
le plus grand public et pour toucher le
grand public eh bien il faut aller vers
la fiction parce que quand on parle
d'image voilà on convaincre mieux donc
on va mieux avec des émotions qu avec
des arguments et l'exemple qui m'a en
plus convaincu c'est l'exemple de blocs
dimon qui était un film avec leonardo
dicaprio et il y avait eu plein de
documentaire sur le trafic illégal de
diamants qui n'avait pas fait bouger les
lignes ils sont les enfants soldats au
sol mais aulas a fini légal de diamants
qui a impliqué les enfants les enfants
soldats et ça n'avait pas fait bouger
les lignes
blood diamond sort j'ai été vérifié les
chiffres parce que j'y croyais pas il ya
eu une baisse de -15% sur le trafic
illégal de diamants et du coup par
extension sur ce qui se passait avec les
enfants soldats et donc je me suis dit
pourquoi on ferait pas un blood forest
qui du coup participerait à faire
baisser la déforestation de 15% et donc
je me suis lancé dans cette aventure là
et poumon vert et tapis rouge n'est pas
encore le bloc fort est que j'espère
mais c'est un cheval de troie c'est à
dire que j'embarque le grand public dans
une aventure des cinémas où je rencontre
juliette binoche claude lelouch et
d'autre et en sous texte je glisse le
combat de francis hallé se botter
d'ajustement francis hallé on va le
retrouver dans un des extraits du film
c'est très très beau d'ailleurs et ayez
une idée très forte là dedans sur la la
canopée de la forêt tropicale où on vous
regarde
notre botaniste pacifiste transformé par
la rage et la douleur en une bête
déterminé prépare un kidnapping
naquirent élus
[Musique]
à force de réécouter tous les
enregistrements que j'avais fait avec
francis je suis convaincu que la canopée
doit être le décor principal de mon film
est urgent de montrer aux gens que les
vrais visages de la forêt cet angle
c'est là qu'il faut l'admirer là elle
est vraiment admirable
si tout le monde pouvait avoir accès à
la canopée il y aurait beaucoup plus de
gens qui serait respectueux de la forêt
parce que vu d'eau dessus
elle et c'est vrai beaucoup plus aimable
beaucoup plus plaisante beaucoup plus
fleuri que celle d'en dessous
elle est faite pour être vue comme la
comme le voit les oiseaux
[Musique]
e
c'est très beau cette idée et vous en
faites le le point de départ de votre
scénario vous imaginez un film qui va
s'appeler the botaniste avec leonardo
dicaprio qui veut y vivra dans une sorte
de dirigeables au dessus de la au dessus
de la forêt seulement évidemment une
fois vous avez écrit le scénario il
voulait même dessiner c'est très beau il
vous faut il vous faut le faire produire
et puis surtout rencontré leonardo
dicaprio et là c'est un peu le sujet du
film c'est la quête qui vous anime ce
qui est très amusant c'est que vous
comprenez assez vite qu'en étant un
réalisateur de documentaire vous n'avez
absolument pas les codes pour réaliser
un film de fiction encore mois pour
réaliser un blockbuster de plusieurs
dizaines de millions de dollars avec
leonardo dicaprio mais ce que j'ai
trouvé très drôle c'est que vous allez
voir plein de gens du cinéma français
pour qu'il vous explique comment faire
org légende du cinéma français font pour
la plupart d'entre eux des téléfilms et
non pas du tout non plus les codes pour
faire un film de plusieurs dizaines de
millions dizaines de millions de dollars
avec leonardo dicaprio
c'est à dire qu'on a l'impression que ce
tas dialogue d'aveuglés de sourds
en fait en fait mon idée c'est de de
partir vers le monde de la fiction avec
une boîte à outils rempli d'outils donc
du coup je vais auprès de ces gens là en
fait j'ai fait cinquante six rencontres
du monde du cinéma là il ya dix neuf
extraits qui apparaissent là mais du
coup je me suis rempli ma boîte à outils
est donc j'ai bien compris je pas assez
naïve faut me dire que je vais être le
réalisateur qui va faire ce blockbuster
à 40 millions parce que dicaprio ne me
connaît pas même si les deux trois
pistes là qui me rapproche très
fortement mais mais voilà mais mon idée
c'est de faire exister ce film dans les
mains d'un haut d'un réalisateur
chevronné autres mois il se trouve que
j'ai écris parce que j'ai compris très
vite que 40 millions ça serait trop pour
moi j'ai écrit le prequel de cette
histoire là en fait l'histoire qui se
passe avant qu'il a pour le coup et une
histoire un million et demi et eric
trois comédiens et donc voilà donc je
vais pouvoir faire mon petit parti par
d'autres groupes bull paraissent comme
est-ce que vous avez rendu compte que
votre film que je trouve très bien 1 par
ailleurs au fond dias et l'ont peut-être
plus long encore sur le cinéma français
que cela façon de sauver la forêt
tropicale c'est à dire que vous quand on
le voit on se dit mais ces gens au fond
il sauterait ils sont pleins de bonne
volonté ils ont envie d'être santé
gentil avec vous des pistes mais ils
sont pas du tout faits ni prêt à faire
des films avec leonardo dicaprio non
plus un autre monde au fonds oui oui je
me suis rendu compte de ça mais en même
temps mon idée c'était pas de leur dire
aidez moi faire un film avec dicaprio
parce que effectivement il ya une marche
mais c'était surtout de d'ouvrir ce
chemin là pour arriver à faire ces films
là et je pense que ces gens sont
convaincus qu'il faut faire plus
attention à l'environnement à la nature
mais met par exemple je pense qu'ils
n'ont pas vu mon film parce que moi
quand je les rencontre ils ont une demi
heure pour moi donc il répondre à mes
questions et ils ont été sincères dans
leurs réponses mais mais j'aimerais que
aujourd'hui il voit ce film là pour
qu'ils comprennent la démarche qui a
vraiment derrière parce que voilà moi je
suis aussi quelque part à un petit don
quichotte a essayé de de dire à tout le
monde et faisons attention à nos forêts
et elles sont l'une des solutions pour
que pour qu'on n'aille pas dans le mur
quoi mais moi j'ai vu votre film peu
après avoir vu je me dis qu'au fond les
forêts tropicales que vous voulez sauver
elles dureront plus longtemps que le
cinéma j'ai l'impression que le cinéma
est bien plus en mauvaise posture
aujourd'hui notamment le cinéma français
que les forêts tropicales
oui alors moi j'ai plus une expertise
sur les forêts que sur le monde du
cinéma puisque justement je le découvre
ce monde du cinéma parce que en fait je
trouve qu'aujourd'hui il ya
95 voire 99 % des films qui sont des
films urbain et ça me rappelle est
pourquoi la bonne raison que ça m'a
rappelé une interview de martin scorsese
qui disait le meilleur conseil qu'on
m'ait donné quand j'ai commencé ce et
tabitha little italy qui est un quartier
de new york donc tu fais tes premiers
films a little italy il ya eu taxi
driver et bien d'autres parce que tu vas
les dialogues vont être juste le tu veux
en connaître l'école des histoires sont
crédibles
donc les réalisateurs qui sont
principalement des urbains font des
films sur des univers qui maîtrisait qui
connaissent donc du coup on arrive à 95%
de film urbain et les gens comme moi qui
sont au coeur de la nature où j'ai vu
via certaines années où je passe lui
mois par an sur le terrain pendant huit
mois je peux pas voir de film et donc ça
fait pas de moi un cinéphile et quand
j'arrive les quatre mois qui restent
mais il faut que je voie mes gamins ma
famille il faut que je monte mes il est
donc je peux pas m'enfermer dans une
salle de cinéma donc du coup moi on va
dire qu'avec d'autres et francis hallé
notamment j'ai une connaissance que
j'aimerais amener au réalisateur de
fiction mais ces deux mondes qui skie
qui vont pas très bien ensemble et
d'ailleurs quand on voit les films qui
sortent à chaque fois qu'ils aient de la
nature c'est un décor c'est un paysage
mais c'est pas le coeur même de du sujet
et même quand on a ou man at work quand
on a dark waters canton à erin
brockovich et autres on est dans la
partie humaine du conflit par rapport à
la nature mais la nature est toujours un
décor même quand on a dit revenante avec
dicaprio le film est très beau mais
qu'est ce qu'on sait de l'écosystème à
part que en montagne quand on monte il
fait froid et que donc voilà ça nous
affaiblit on se met dans race valmore
pour garder la chaleur enfin voilà ya
donc du coup je rêve d'un film ultime où
la nature dont l'occurrence la forêt
soit le personnage central du film mais
il a bien vu par le passé il ya eu en
moi je pense à dark souls à la le film
de de cure aux as was sur la toundra
d'autres penserait à danse avec les
loups le film de kevin coster affaire
d'ars aux malades mais oui mais tous les
goûts sont dans la nature justement vous
vous croyez encore aux films engagés au
fait au film à message vous pensez que
ça peut marcher encore aujourd'hui mais
j'aimerais bien qu'on arrive à faire un
blog forez comme il ya eu blood diamond
oui parce que je pense que il faut
toucher les gens par l'émotion vous
prenez deux personnes une de gauche et
de droite elle se retrouve à un dîner
entre amis ou au bureau et vont se
balancer tous les arguments possibles
elles vont se quitter pas une qui aura
bougé d'un iota sur sa position si on a
les deux mêmes personnes mais tu y en a
un qui raconte une histoire personnelle
qui va émouvoir l'autre et soi lui faire
écraser une larme haute et un chemin de
convergence possible et c'est ce chemin
là que je trouvais donc du coup le
cinéma pour le coup a plus de forces
emotionnellement que le documentaire
donc je me lance voilà dans cette
croisade là alors dernière question est
ce que vous pensez pas qu aujourd'hui la
série a encore plus de force que le psy
débat qui lui même avait plus de force
que le documentaire est peut-être au
fond c'est plus facile de faire une
série quand on est luc marescot que de
faire un film avec avec leonardo
dicaprio oui alors maintenant si c'est
viggo mortensen
donc je dirais oui quand même mais oui
la série ça peut être l'une des choses
il se trouve qu'il ya deux éditeurs qui
ont lu le scénario du botaniste qu'ils
ont adoré et finalement ça va sortir en
bouquins la scéne au belize et en ce
moment ça va sortir en bouquins chez
fayard début 2022 et effectivement j'ai
eu des retours de 10 ans mais tu as
écrit enfin vous avez écrit avec
guillaume un truc tellement fort et long
ça ferait un film trop long il faudra en
faire une série donc du coup
effectivement on est peut-être sur la
piste d'une série est au fond n'en
parlera plus dans les dîners que si
c'était un film
merci lui et maresco en tout cas le film
que vous avez fait comme on verrait
tapis rouge lui il est déjà sorti et il
est très très bien et on se retrouve
tout de suite avec nicolas henry
[Musique]
nicolas henry vous êtes photographe et
c'est vous qui produisait avec
l'association le tour du monde la
biennale photo climat qui a lieu à paris
en extérieur dans 11 lieux de la
capitale jusqu'au 17 octobre et qui a
donné ce livre photo climat on y revient
dans un instant on commence par la photo
qui symbolise à vos yeux notre époque et
cette photo la voici
pourquoi celle-ci pourquoi ces
préservatifs sur la place de sur le bisc
de la concorde c'était enfants et c'est
peut-être une des images qui m'a marqué
le plus en fait quand j'ai découverte
donc on est bien d'accord que c'était au
20e siècle il enseigne à un moment où
c'est sûr c'était au moment du début
d'act up et ça a été un moment où ils
ont été médiatisés d'une manière
incroyable et en fait moi j'avais des
aspirations artistiques mais je savais
pas j'avais pas lu ou compris conscience
dans l'engagement que pourrait prendre
un acte pareil et quand j'ai découvert
ça le jt déjà j'ai trouvé ça magnifique
tout d'un coup que cette obélix avec
toute son histoire en fait soit avec une
capote rose dessus et puis je me suis
rendu compte que finalement ils avaient
une fonction d'activer la société de
créer une crise de conscience et nous
fait nous transformer et je pense que
pour moi avec certains événements de mon
enfance a été extrêmement fondateur au
fond et explique le but que vous
poursuivez aujourd'hui avec une biennale
comme ce tout qui m'a alors le peut-être
alors dans photo climat en fait on a des
grandes scénographie qui sont sur les
grandes places de paris et la bastille
l'hôtel de ville le vosges la place du
palais royal et en fait on a un
plaidoyer c'est à dire qu on a trente
associations et 30 artistes voilà donc
au fait des grandes formes comme ça
c'est le cas en 2010 9,1 je crois ça
c'est l'expo fondatrice en fait j'ai été
on est c'était emmaüs qui m'a contacté
moi je depuis 15 ans je voyageais dans
le monde à faire des théâtres pour
passer la parole devant l'engagement des
gens emmaüs m'a demandé de faire leurs
70 ans du coup pendant deux ans j'ai
travaillé sur la grande pauvreté en
france si on a fait cette espèce
d'énorme volume d'installation devant le
devant le conseil d'état entre louis
conseil d'état avec une grande vague de
migrants tendant la main à quelqu'un qui
était dans l'eau j'avais fait à gori et
donc c'est un peu fondateur c'est à dire
à partir de dons qu'on avait une
éco-conception tous les cadres étaient
faits en encombrant c'était ma muse et
de là on m'a proposé plusieurs autres
expos il ya lire et faire lire je sais
pas surveiller ce mouvement incroyable
c'est 25 grands parents qui disent aux
enfants de la france entière l'a donc
avait alexandre jardin pennac ce qui
manie le grand écrivain ont contacté on
a fait une autre expo en mai mais ce qui
m'intéressait et ce que j'ai été très
touché et déjà de l'honneur de
représenter ces ong mais de l'autre côté
en fait c'étaient des mouvements
spontanés emmaüs quand l'abbé pierre il
dit un pauvre de tendre la main à notre
pauvre et ensemble ils vont sortir de la
pauvreté après 70 ans et des centaines
de milliers de personnes qui sont
sorties de la pauvreté c'est un
mouvement qui est totalement indépendant
emmaüs france donc aujourd'hui on a 28
le compagnon ils sont indépendants et
pareil les grands-parents du coup on se
mobilise les grands parents du temps et
ils vont raconter des histoires aux
enfants lutter contre
l'analphabétisation et tout ça est ce
que je trouvais et c'est qu'en réponse à
la crise parce qu'on fait un constat
d'échec très dur la photokina à partir
du constat climatique et dans le social
et environnemental il ya aussi tous les
jours des énergies des idées qui
naissent et qui sont transformatrice et
un niveau incroyable et du coude en
photo climat on a essayé de mettre en
oeuvre un certain nombre de cette idée
les montrer donc il ya un côté qu'un
petit peu alarmiste on peut considérer
par exemple on est une autre image c'est
la ferrade bouddha on a envoyé quatre
reporters avec action contre la faim ce
dans les camps de réfugiés les régions
pour comprendre en fait que aujourd'hui
en fait on a énormément de réfugiés
climatiques dans les camps et acf qu'un
des plus grands acteurs mondiale en fait
de ça quand je les ai contactés ils
m'ont dit la faute au climat ça nous
intéresse parfaitement c'était étonnant
c'est purement sociale cds ingénieurs
zine ans tous les jours en fait on a
besoin de ça on a besoin d'un plaidoyer
et du coup le fait de l'avoir mis là
devant la place de l'hôtel de ville on a
tout un village autour de la question de
l'eau et des réfugiés c'est une manière
voilà de sensibiliser et d'amener un
public très large à
l'ajustement regardons à septembre de
deux photographes que vous exposez dans
cette biennale encore une fois onze
lieux différents dans paris 1 par
exemple chez lui si lucas foglia
qu'est ce que c'est le cas sous les
balles à c'est un cri un peu
métaphorique le cas c'est un jeune
artiste américain qui a encore plus très
complexe et très complet sur une vision
très moderne de l'écologie aux états
unis et donc on a il y avait ce cri je
trouve qu'ils étaient un peu
extraordinaire comme si la terre se
réveiller autour d'un personnage donc là
c'est une écriture plus métaphorique
mais dans cette exposition aux frises le
documentaire avec quand même un certain
nombre d'informations très précises et
alors on a pour le mettre en scène voilà
on a eu notre lassé des capteurs de
sensations par rapport à des programmes
ou des gens sont immergés dans la nature
donc dans le travail de lukas on l'a mis
sur des vagues de bois en face le louvre
avec un ancien décor de la comédie
française qu'on a entièrement recyclé
les recycler est apte à l'éco-conception
et l'éco-conception à l'e3 mais
évidemment on peut pas parler de ces
sujets sans s'en est aussi dans l'effort
technique et donc ça c'est assez
intéressant et la fondation hulot a ils
m'ont donné un cabinet d'ingénierie
environnementale monsieur madame
recyclage nous deux jeunes gens et on a
vraiment travaillé ensemble comment faut
faire pour faire mieux mais en fait il
ya des endroits où on a une dent creuse
n'y a pas de technologie en fait pour
changer mais par contre il ya aussi
beaucoup de choses en bonne intelligence
on a eu des chantiers de réinsertion
sociale avec trois pays à qui rien sert
des jeunes qui sont sortis des écoles du
nouveau fesa cad re mans avec
d'anciennes palette on a eu on a eu
plein de gens qui nous enjoint en fait
on a essayé de maximiser d'abord en
bonne intelligence en fait sur notre éco
conception et puis après on a toujours
une limite par exemple des transports
des choses comme ça où il faut faire une
compensation carbone tout ça alors je
continue notre exploration tous les
photographes qui sont exposés dont vous
nicolas en rivaux b jean qu'on peut voir
à l'église saint-eustache on envoie un
là les chevaux blancs
alors qu'est ce en quoi c'est quel
rapport avec le climat c'est la question
qu'on se pose quand on fait des photos
climat c'est la biennale social et
environnemental et en fait quand on a
travaillé avec la paroisse de
saint-eustache six mois j'apparaissais
il y avait un projet sur une église en
fait je voulais être en dialogue avec le
tueur et les paroissiens et il y avait
l'idée d'une religion un peu originel où
la nature était au centre en fait nos
grandes religions sa demi volée d'auxi
et en fait on en a l'image que vous avez
vu avant l été en france on en a fait en
bretagne on en a fait en casamance et
donc on allait chercher des légendes en
fait où le spirituel et elle y est en
fait à la nature et ça reprenait aussi
le l'encyclique du pape en fait qui a
parlé beaucoup d'écologie société dans
sa dernière encyclique et donc où on a
mis en scène ça comme des grandes
bannières sur saint-eustache et en fait
c'est un des premiers projets
c'est-à-dire qu'à la suite d'emmaüs
cette paloise mais demandez l'exposition
et puis d'un autre côté la fondation le
marchand était venu me voir pour faire
un tour de france des ong et donc il ya
deux projets qui ont survécu après
l'engouement d'années a finalement tout
30 ong et 30 artistes mais c'est une
manière voilà deux de créer un esprit de
la nature alors on a des expos très
documentaire donc un engagement très
précis on a des expos très métaphorique
donc là par exemple ses camarades in
inquiète australienne c'est le convoi
est justement sur sur le livre
là c'est plus métaphorique alors en fait
tamara dean elle travaille avec des
jeunes gens des danseurs et à le travail
sur l'animalité la nature et donc dans
le corps plus de son oeuvre on a
énormément de mise en scène assez
étrange assez métaphorique avec ce lien
là c'est un auto portrait d'elle en fait
à elle où elle en train de danser avec
un arbre dans la couverture du livre
voilà qu'on a choisie pour la couverture
ce qu'on trouvait qu'il y avait cette
danse était extraordinaire et puis en
fait cette expo la mise sous la canopée
des halles et la canopée des halles où
on à l'arrivée du rer on a tous ces
jeunes qui viennent par tous du grand
paris on essaie plutôt un endroit où se
croisent toute la jeunesse voilà jeté
les baskets médiane mais est finalement
l'expo ce qui est incroyable c'est
qu'elle est rentrée elle est remplie par
tous ces jeunes qui dansent dans un coin
qui viennent avec leur son est
finalement je trouve qu'elle a eu la
drôle parce qu'on a beaucoup entendu
parler de la canopée de la forêt dans
cette émission mais qu'est ce que c'est
que la canopée des halles alors en fait
dans l'architecturé des halles ce qu'on
appelle la canopée c'est énorme au vent
enfin la centrale voilà et donc non l'a
habité par des danseurs en écho en fête
avec toute cette jeunesse à ces
merveilleuses qui se croisent à cet
endroit regardons les photos de leila
alaoui sur des portraits de marocains
c'est beau d'ailleurs pourquoi avez vous
choisi cela allait là c'est aussi une
histoire c'est à dire qu'elle alors elle
est là on l'aimé énormément c'était une
magnifique jeune femme reporter et au
moment où elle travaillait pour un an
mais distille internationale elle a été
assassinée dans les uns dans les
attentats de ouagadougou et à l'époque
elle faisait aussi ce travail qui était
un travail très minimal en fait au maroc
avec des portraits extrêmement beau sur
dur du noir et qui était aussi une
manière de faire une réponse sans
identité avec une très grande fierté en
fait de ces populations et du coup les
lacs est devenu à partir des attentats
aussi une figure pour la mairie de paris
on avait des portraits un petit peu dans
beaucoup d'institutions on souhaitait la
mettre donc on a pavoisé en fait
l'église saint merri avec ses grands
personnages qui sont immenses derrière
la maco fanta nothing et dû niki de
saint phalle et c'est une expo qui porte
beaucoup d'émotion cette année mais là
on est à nouveau en guinée d'une manière
différente ce qui est intéressant c'est
que sur cette question d'engagement en
fait on arrive à plein de manières en
fait de l'envisager parce que quelles
que soient ses talents en tant qu'acteur
de la société conçoit ingénieurs à artix
agriculteurs en fait on peut trouver
dans cet écosystème incroyable des
associations en fait des solutions pour
se transformer en france il ya 12
millions de bénévoles dans les
associations oui donc c'est une culture
qui est extraordinaire donc on a une
vraie volonté on a une vraie force est
une vraie force 10 d autres exemples
aïda amis lune et les ailes et
éthiopienne
là aussi des images très métaphorique
aïda est là de par son histoire des
halles a construit le festival d'addis
abeba c'est une fille qui est très
engagée depuis toujours et à lavit et
contacté par water aid water aid c'est
la plus grosse ong au monde concernant
l'eau et elle a produit cette série
alors qu'un peu afro féministes qui est
aussi afro futuriste où elle se met en
scène en fait elle même dans un cône et
spes deux quotidiens un peu fantasmée et
qui part au fait d'un univers d'une
maison pour aller dans le désert du
danakil en ethiopie qu un des endroits
les plus secs du monde où elle va
justement créé des métaphores un peu
surréel mais se mettre en personnage un
peu ou sauveur ou ou dans un monde
complètement asséché sur le prendre à
côté ou de l'autre et aida c'est un
artiste donc éthiopienne dans la
biennale on a des gens qui est du monde
entier d'australie la d'ethiopie au
brésil j'aimerais qu'on regarde avant la
fin aussi floriane de lassée ces
portraits de marcheurs
floriane c'est donc une artiste
française et elle a une métaphore en
fait on c'est aussi ma compagne on a
voyagé pendant des années ensemble et
donc elle est aussi co directrice du
festival et en fait on a pendant des
années elle a voyagé et elle faisait une
métaphore en faisant porter sur la tête
des gens à tout un tas de leur destin de
ces réponses qu'on voit très souvent
quand on voyage on voit des gens qui
venaient à leur tête des choses qui nous
paraissent à portable voilà donc on en a
fait une métaphore un peu la chose
c'est peut-être je suis en cache un
artifice mais c'est une peinture
symboliste c'est à dire que cette jeune
fille en ethiopie et va porter le groupe
le mois mais elle aussi elle doit
prendre soin de sa chèvre finalement il
se retrouve avec tout ces nécessités
alors que peut-être cette jeune femme
elle serait mieux à l'école met donc
c'est des métaphores de vie c'est des
métaphores
et c'est un théâtre alors dont on a
énormément proposer des propositions
d'artistes qui travaillent de manière
théâtrale c'est avec des costumes des
mises en scène une sorte de grande joie
de vivre ya aussi un côté très festif en
fait à même si on aborde des sujets très
sérieux et donc c'est dans 11 lieux en
extérieur dans paris c'est jusqu'au 17
octobre ça s'appelle photo kl ebace est
une biennale on est sûr de la retrouver
l'année prochaine et chaque année où ça
sera dans deux ans
la wii biennale dans le fichage est donc
ça serait en 2023 et oui oui au ballon
on a vraiment le veut on a énormément de
projets qu'on nous propose
quotidiennement depuis que les gens vu
ses apparitions de grandes scénographie
dans la ville et ce qui est intéressant
c'est que à la fois les pouvoirs publics
s'engagent des fondations des ong des
artistes est en fait ce microcosme y
réfléchisse ensemble et du coup photo
climat c'est aussi d'un autre côté une
manière de pouvoir amener tout
interlocuteur à vivre cette idée est
peut-être arrivé aussi une
transformation pour cet ensemble
d'interlocuteurs voilà c'est le nôtre
veut merci nicolas henry merci de nous
avoir suivi cette 500ème émission se
termine et et rendez vos prochains
numéros la 501ème donc
[Musique]